The best way to become familiar with objects is to use lots of them. Here, we
will look at strings and we will do it in three ways. With BlueJ objects, with
Java code, and with another nifty tool called the code pad. In the code pad, as
you'll see in a minute, I can type in code and have it executed right away
without having to compile anything, or without having to click on the bubbles.
The code pad is so nifty that it's a shame that it's hidden, to reveal it,
select View and Show Code Pad. And then they make it so small, which is also a
shame. Let's make it much, much bigger. In the code pad I can write regular
Java statements. Here I declare a variable, here I have a print statement. And
as soon as I hit the Enter key, it gets executed. You see a window pops up that
has the output. But what's even better, any value that I type in here gets
displayed right away. Let me show you. I type river.length, and the answer 11
is displayed as soon as I hit the Enter key. It's important that you don't type
a semi-colon because otherwise the code pad thinks that you have a statement
like up here. No semicolon tells it that it should immediately print the value
of the code that you write. Here I type the name of the variable without a
semicolon, and it's printed the string Mississippi. And to the left, I have a
little blob that I can drag into the workbench. Here it goes. I drop it into
the workbench. Now I'm supposed to give it a name. I'll give it the same name,
that the variable has river. And over here I have a familiar BlueJ blob. That I
can manipulate in the usual way. I can right click on it, and now the string
class has many, many methods, but I want to call length. When I select the
length method I get the answer 11. So I can get the same answer in two
different ways. Which one is better? It really depends. Sometimes I prefer to
use the BlueJ bubbles for quick experimentation, because you can't really make
any typos. Sometimes I prefer to use the code pad. Because it's just easier to
type in, maybe to copy and paste in, what you want. Both of those are great for
experimenting with classes and objects, and to just find out what happens when
you call a particular method. You should try them both and see which one you
like better. Of course for more hardcore programming. For writing a program
that gets repeated over and over again, one wants to write an actual Java class
with a main method. In that case, as you know, you right click on the empty
space, make a new class, right click, open the editor. And start typing. Then
you put your code into the main method. Here I wrote a couple of lines of code
that let me compute the length of this string. You compile. You run. And you
get the answer. That's more work at first, and it'll pay off when you write a
longer program. For short explorations, the object bubbles and the code pad are
hard to beat. So go ahead. Fire up BlueJ and work along with Sara to explore
the string class and its methods.